if success follows a power law
distribution
how can we expect everyone to be a
success in this economy which is kind of
similar to you know people say if
everyone's rich no one's rich right like
how do you well it's power law
distribution on a particular thing but
you can have many power laws because you
can have many different things you
compete on right someone can be a
youtube star someone else can be a
youtube comedy star someone else can be
a youtube comedy star in taiwan so
there's many many ways to slice things
yes only one person can be the top of
the leaderboards but you can have many
many many leaderboards the internet
creates
millions and billions of niches
and so you can have millions and
billions of people and if each one is
relatively authentic they can kind of do
their own thing now in the sense that
money is a single score card then yeah
in the money game there will always be
someone higher up than you and they'll
always be someone lower down than you
but that's not necessarily a cause for
alarm as long as you can meet your basic
needs and it's making a good living for
you and you're having fun doing it
that's enough
these are not zero-sum games the economy
is not a zero-sum game the internet
economy is certainly not a zero-sum game
it's status hierarchies are zero-sum
games and if you're overly concerned
with status hierarchy sure you'll never
be happy you'll never be satisfied but
if you're fine with the
the the wealth hierarchy where you only
need to hit a certain threshold and your
basic needs are taken care of then we
can all get there
yeah it's more about the absolute number
of people who are earning a living
and getting by versus you know the
people how much how many people are
making gazillions of dollars um i mean
do you think that like you know the
competition it is getting easier to get
started right there are more newsletters
and more podcasts and more all sorts of
things uh do you think it's there's
harder to start today
there's always an advantage to being
first in any given medium like uh ben
here is a poster child for the paid
newsletter before there was such a thing
that was doing it and in fact you know
even on substance the people who started
early like the uh
matt tybees and the glenn green walls
and the matthew iglesias of the world
and the burn hobart they get an
advantage because
when people first wander into that
medium
they look around they're like well who's
here and so early adopters do get a leg
up and later adopters will have to work
more for it but doesn't mean they can't
be successful
but there is an advantage to being sort
of a connoisseur and figuring out which
platform's going to do well and adopting
them early on clubhouse an example i
i've met people in clubhouse over a
million followers and i'm like who the
hell is this person that's not even
interesting but they were on there early
and they got into this user module or
they kind of built a fan base early on
when nobody else was around and
available and that that pays off it's a
bet that they took and that bet paid off
yeah yeah how do you how do you promote
yourself today like if you were getting
started from scratch today
how would you how would you get started
i don't i don't believe in
self-promotion i think that the world is
really craving is authenticity very very
few people are actually authentic a lot
of people are putting on a show or
wearing a mask and i think people deep
down in their gut they know when
someone's putting on a show and when
they're not and so i think people crave
truth and when they find someone who is
speaking
their truth and is being authentic and
honest that is naturally attractive it
doesn't necessarily pay dividends
immediately it doesn't necessarily pay
dividends in the in a way that can be
easily measured in track but it builds
you the single most important thing
which is credibility credibility matters
more than distribution
so a thousand true fans matters more
than having a hundred thousand weak fans
there's a lot of people on twitter
who'll say things that are like
non-controversial they're very careful
and bland and they'll have a big
follower account but when you actually
look at the engagement on their tweets
and you look at the actual how much
people care or listen to those people
it's actually quite low
so i would argue that authenticity is a
thing that you want uh and that will
lead to credibility
not follower accounts and not the
metrics that twitter and clubhouse want
you to play at
yeah i mean i think you have to find out
what you want to do
you have to like i think that is the
hard part is actually figuring out what
what feels like play to you right i
think that if you can find that out then
then you will be able to find the
thousand true fans i think if you're
dreaming yeah yeah yeah yeah
just observe yourself what is it that
you do for fun what do you enjoy doing
no one's gonna be able to compete with
you on that and so the best way to
figure that out is literally to observe
your own behavior that takes time you
can't rush it but you'll figure it out
eventually and if not your friends and
your family around you will
yeah i feel like most people it's it's
like when someone's you know a
relationship isn't working out i feel
like everyone else figures it out before
you do
that's right
you have it right you have an idealized
relationship that you desire that you're
aiming for and that's what you're
holding in your head well they're seeing
the reality of the actual relationship
that you're in
yeah so people people know what you
should be doing generally it might be
the thing that you're doing on friday
nights like
it yeah
that's interesting
so i would just add just i would just
add two things to it naval said uh first
off uh it's kind of annoying with naval
because it's funny how many people miss
the idea that the internet inverts
everything where yes there's a power
curve but they've already beat me to the
point there's infinite power curves
available to be filled but i think that
leads to a way to dig deeper on that is
there's lots of ways to differentiate
and everyone's like oh you have to
differentiate by being the best writer
the most clever and actually you can
also differentiate just by virtue of
which niche you fill if no one is
talking about a particular topic or no
one is covering a particular subject
that by definition is differentiation
even if you're only average at it just
by being the only one doing it is a real
opportunity number one
and then number two
i push back a little bit on the whole
passion or what you find fun just
because i think what is fun
is being really good at something and
you get very passionate about something
if you spend all your time doing it
and there i think there's a function
where there's so many things to cover so
many things to talk about and if you do
it and you practice it and you get
better and better and better at it
you're going to turn around and suddenly
realize you're super passionate about it
at the same time and so i think there's
a like there's a bit where all this is
true you want to find something you do
for fun
and you want to be differentiated have a
niche
but
the order in which that happens and the
opportunity is revealed i think is kind
of the opposite of what everyone sort of
assumes it is
yeah i mean riffing on that for a second
like
um product market fit has a way of
creating passion like i've seen a lot of
companies where like they get product
market fit and the founder is really
passionate and a company doesn't have
product market fit and the founders
aren't that passionate or then they find
product market fit later and then
suddenly everybody's passionate so they
they do kind of go together it is hard
to say which came first
um so i think that is a very important
point to bring up yeah
well i think by the way
the other thing that's exciting about
this sort of subscription thing i mean
i've been
i've been very excited about the
potential for this model for like local
journalism like very niche sort of
things
and it's a great example where if like
the geography still matters right
geography
didn't work for a business offer
newspapers once it sort of fell apart
but that's because their cost structures
were way too large to sustain it but
that doesn't mean people still don't
have sort of local concerns for example
and local concerns could be geographic
they could also be on the internet right
covering a game covering a particular
company or something along those lines
and to me there's
i i think that yeah maybe it's a little
late if you want to be a general tech
blogger right i thought i was too late
when i started in 2013 but
it's very very early for i think just a
massive massive number of niches
and what's impressive about ben is he's
always tinkering so when he did uh
strategy as kind of the first real paid
blog out there or newsletter
um he was just playing around and then
by the time other people started doing
paid newsletters through sub stacks he's
on to dithering where he's doing paid
podcasts
and uh you know kind of these serial
episodic paid podcasts that are bundled
with his newsletter so there's this
tinkering mentality that can kind of
keep you ahead of the curve if you want
to if you're an early adopter type now
by the way when i say what feels i play
to you that's just half of the the thing
that's not enough the the whole phrase
is what feels like play to you
but looks like work to others and all
those words are deliberately chosen
like feels like because it's your
internal feeling like play so it's fun
but looks because the outside person
doesn't have the feel
like work to them and if it looks like
work to them then you can monetize it
and it can be useful so all four of
those pieces are important in that
sentence all of those criteria have to
be fulfilled for you to find something
that is a worthwhile endeavor where
essentially it's your hobby but it's
everybody else's vocation it's your
avocation their vocation and then you
can out compete them in that and and do
well and enjoy every step of the way
like i my senses for example then i
listened to your podcast your dithering
podcast uh with john gruber and it just
sounds like you guys are just having fun
i mean it's just like two friends
chatting right and no one's gonna
compete with you on that because it's
just two friends chatting about the tech
industry and they have a genuine love
for the tech industry so they're
enjoying themselves um so there's
there's just no way to compete with that
because you can't lose
well this is well the other thing too
you
is
you
that's the
ultimate differentiation that by
definition no one can compete with is
being yourself because there's only one
you so to the extent you can get to that
i think that's right and i also love
your point about it feels like work to
others
this is my biggest group as like as a
kid
was i had it stuck in my head that the
subjects i needed to study
whichever ones were hard for me were the
important ones and the ones that were
easy for me were not important at all
and so i spent my time taking classes
and focusing on like majors that were
very very difficult and finally i kind
of like gave up on that halfway through
college and i was going to do classes
that sound awesome and that i like and
then like it's so like the whole world
opened up to me and and i think it was a
weird mindset i don't know if it's
common to people but simply one that i
fell into that like oh if it's
challenging yeah this is yeah there's a
common track right like people try to
fix their weaknesses whenever you want
to double down your strengths
but even when you double down your
strengths you want to go to the things
you're strong on and then find the
hardest things in that domain and hone
yourself against those so you get even
stronger
uh so it's like if you're reading a book
that's really difficult and you kind of
are confused if it's something you're
interested in you will reread it you
really read it you keep going where the
points until you get it it's the same as
like when you feel soreness or pain
after lifting weights you're gonna build
stronger muscles on the other hand if
it's a topic you're not interested in
you'll just wander off and you'll just
never get anywhere on it so i don't
believe in trying to cover your
weaknesses especially in a non-linear
world with specialization of labor where
you can hire other people to cover your
weaknesses or partner with other people
to cover your weaknesses so you really
just want to double down on your
strengths and to do that you always have
to be at the cutting edge of your domain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you